la pina intro amiche che dalla vita che
non siano i video dai forza dai mezzi
che pensavo dicessi qualche cagata
invece sei stato molto se ora ma no ma
no a questa dittatura racconti cosa
abbiamo fatto ieri allora è successa una
cosa simpatica ieri abbiamo recato due
ore di una bomba in lei due ore
abbondanti di un gameplay ed è finito
nel cesso perché non ha registrato
l'audio di di pietro e leo che sono qui
presenti oggi oggi ragazzi giocavano
gioco incredibile ma c'era anche
l'avviso di attenzione all'inizio perché
bisogna anche fare attenzione a non
utilizzare la parte negativa di questo
gioco che sono i più 4 di tutte le cose
che possono farvi inimicare una persona
in questo caso inizia con la p e finisce
con la o
sto parlando ovviamente di paolo che è
una persona andiamo avanti vediamo se
riusciamo a fare una partita decente a
uno ci siano ragazzi questa è la partita
siamo io leo pietro è una quarta persona
che sarà un bot
io non vorrei sclerare ha vinto un po
perché avessi sono le prove perché ha
vinto un bot
mai pietro puoi farcela provo a
comunicare con mio po no no quell'altro
mette uso io ti ammazzo ok ok non posso
comunicare confronto che non ti capisce
però se con la mente se ci parli un
pochettino può capirti sbircio le carte
allievi tutto questo no ce l'hai leo
celo celo celo ce la faceva a darvi
dentro è piccolo e opprimente madaio
nono su altra sfida non avevo tolta la
sfida ho visto in mente le tue carte
vale foresta c'è la pesca a strascico
ascolta domanda domanda no ok io ho
tolto la sfida sfida sarebbe quando uno
quando uno butta un più 4 l'altro può
capire se vuole contestare sei veramente
hai quel colore lee kai scelto se ce
l'hai per scritto quattro gatti se non
lui né pesca sei solo che avevo bisogno
dalla sua però va beh posso no grosso
zero cioè che senza non ci fossero più a
ok ok ora zitti zitti
io sfido tanto nel dubbio perso ci ha
sentito mio fa semiti barusso ridevo
leoci ai 16 carte davvero come ca verbal
non le vogliono
giuro che se non è un lurido album su
cui attaccarle non ho bravo che veder
detenzione del fiore che lavora c'è la
buona per cui fate a pesca non più
guardare
se ha detto rosso al 2 rosso io sfido le
prende lui
esatto sì sì sì sì sì vabbè che guarda
alle altre carte da giocare
io ho giocato 24 io non ho capito che
stai vivendo io come funziona stare
gomito aveva chiarito suello ma raven
non vale questa non abbiamo capito le
regole che scontano le possibile questa
la paghiamo
limitiamo la quarta partita dalla pietro
sarà la mia sinistra in questa ragazzi
siete pronti questa sarà una signora
partita andiamo avanti la gara la cow
boy secco
peccato il solo a me stava simpatico mio
po perché me l'avete fatto kikar fuori
mio po che non è orribile il cavo è a
fortissimo comunque non vorrei dire ma
sai perché lui non capivamo ai colori
perché il mio per davvero che non
capisci colori io appena metti da
lontano
se non si doveva chiamare dal tonic
spesso vedo da piccolo sua marche ripa
come lo vuole chiamare suo figlio mio
poco signora e sicura questa è la
chiamato cowboy questa no va dai pietro
tavolo messo controllore non è capita
basta ok io provo solo questo non ho uno
meno male che lo puoi dire quando nei
due in mano perché sono un casino
grazie al cielo a ok a voi stavate il 7
kagasoff mazza quello cha tutte le carte
ciao a tutte le cautele caso e
guardalinee si mettono d'accordo lui e
cowboy provo figli smonto le braccia
diventi un bimbi non è detto no quant'è
cosa ci hai tu lei cosa ha una caratura
possa far nient'altro che questo signore
non ci voglio credere
come si chicca la gente giusto gioco red
tig c'è il ban
posso mandare sono lost e la partita
fatemi bando no basta lo volevo fare
questo lo preleva con lo strascico me
dai facciamo ancora la rai smettere di
vincere le partite pietro per cortesia
ora quest'altro madonna
smonto le bravi per praticare poi tutto
frullatore idiota che non sei altro
questo 40 io guardo non basta all 8 il
miglior compagno di squadra ma mai
trattore neanche vicino a te come ora
che mi mette quello che non c'è è meno
male parata ammazzo piccole ruote
diventi una fiat panda torico
elettronici a che sta partito e chi
giuro che il gioco assi ortiz con leo è
veramente me ne vado poi come ragazzi
non ce l'ha hai fatto allora vi sono
tanti ma perché io sono un uomo col
sangue freddo cioè di quelli che
facevano le sparatorie ai tempi dei
cowboy anno lui e cavoli ok capo il
continua imperterrito a pescare e che
mirava veniva data partita signori
proprio loro la ribaltano allora loro
alleanza la facciamo esatto sardo e non
posso non posso farlo il più vero ok
ragazzi ma tutti lì e attenzione questa
difficile ancora sempre a 1 ma come fa a
vincere sempre marco banchetto dopo
muore uno o 11 maledizione che poi sono
la posso mettere non c'è giallo non c'è
il giallo ma c'era proprio un file è che
non c ero io abbiamo tradimento peggiore
di come uno ok eleonora ragazzi
bravissimo lei luciano benissimo orca
vacca ragazzi non ce l'ho
se lui a l'azzurro ha vinto oddio
servita l'azzurra vinto signore e
signori
basta
re partite e basta attivo tutto tranne
quella va bene allora abbiamo ribattere
ok 70 uno studio gioca un 7 per
scambiare le carte e 70
manca tutto un gioco tutto candore
scabec aspes casa lascia tutto tra le
pedane per sei un uomo si sono un uomo
ma la partita vorrei che finisca entro
oggi la partita dura 6 anni però noi ci
proviamo vamonos ma scusatemi cos'è sta
roba lesse quindi momento un 7 e scambio
le carte ma quindi voglio né di pietro
c'è il 7 diventa una carta speciale per
forza anche lo zero che avere carte mi
pare ma come non era possibile cioè
infattibile st modalità ve lo dico anche
perché se tu hai chi di un 7 in mano
vuol dire che le puoi scambiare otto
volte non le vuole scambiare otto volte
porco demonio abbiamo già vinto le coppe
due volte porca vacca che schifo basta
dove scherma quarto ai giochi in
automatico adesso ok che c'era il potere
del gioco automaticamente la carta ma
poi tenere io ho sette carte sennò 15
caso sei carte cioè continua a pescare
ciao pietro cijan domani è arrivato ora
casanova ma com'è possibile che devasta
1 ma con vai vai vai vai non può vincere
legno o 87 no mamma mia
le mele d'oro a dopo un hub e adesso ve
li prendo quindi non potevano pulirlo va
bene fa niente ok dato che cartuccia
cowboy nudo ed è che ha battuto questa
vicenda quello di pietro quindi propongo
è vero che li prendiamo quello su quando
le api nova nuova pezzo di il robot
inutile basta con i danni con le catene
aveva 87 in mano ma come è si ovvero non
ce l'hanno certo dico io perché verrà
pescara era un non eletto 1 anno si ho
detto questo io devo avere per forza
[Musica]
la modalità sfida che grave mi frega
e non è tutto rosa aveva non c'è una
bella sfida perché io attivato ma la
modalità sfida non c'è no no no no no
kim kim maledizione la vita il cartello
di cartone o che carte aveva lui leo è
questo vanno aspettati procedere subito
questo qua questa qua intendi donna
aspettami lo sto per dire da voglio fare
perché no il cinema non ho fatto in
tempo a dire però siamo proprio quella
sporca ma tutto questo ma l'altro una
pescata 8 titolo ha capito niente
proprio antonio ti va bene una puntata
con sa com'è possibile tutto il mio non
ho vinto niente dai che sfiga ma basta
basta mi rifiuto di parlare io signori
vi ringrazio per ha visto il video
ringrazio leo ringrazio fine troverà mai
partecipato aver vinto torniamo pietro
non lo ringrazio spero che vi sia
piaciuto sia chat e tassi iscritti mi
piace e la campo degli epicentri
iscritti è sempre importante e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo vino dai
ragazzi
[Musica]